immigration is one of the most divisive
issues in the country including the
battle over the so-called dreamers but
you may not have heard that concern over
immigration policy has led to a surge in
applications for citizenship among those
currently holding green cards and some
of those seeking to become full citizens
are getting help from an unlikely source
using Americana to help create Americans
so this was the United States in its
entirety in the beginning this is how we
started out as a country on the bottom
floor of New York City's oldest Museum
groups of immigrants are working to
become American citizens they range in
age origin and aspirations how long have
you been in America fifty-seven years so
why now because I want to vote green
card holders like Ingrid Kaminsky are
part of the citizenship project the free
six-week course uses artifacts from the
New York Historical Society to help
students pass the civics test required
to become a citizen the Louisiana
Purchase okay so how would you describe
the Louisiana Purchase it's large right
in the classroom a map shows how the
Louisiana Purchase doubled the size of
the United States but the real lesson
happens at the exhibit a red stain on
the official document signed by Napoleon
it's not blood what else is red and
popular and free wine wine very good
this is a wine stain on the Louisiana
Purchase original document these details
add humanity to the history which might
just help the students pass the test
because when you think about it you
think about the fact that he was just a
ruler who I'm a wine drinker so I think
a body like it happened to me
hiroshima agüero emigrated from the
dominican republic just nine months ago
she's taking this course with her mother
do you think about America differently
knowing more about its history from
America's always been a great country
and learning about the culture and mall
deeper and about the history it's even
more important and it makes you feel
very happy and it makes you feel you I
should have made the right decision of
coming over the Historical Society in
partnership with the City University of
New York began the project after
President Trump announced a travel ban
on certain visitors at the start of his
administration it's time to begin moving
toward a merit-based immigration system
while the ban is still working its way
through the courts
his current immigration proposal aims to
cut legal immigration in half we've been
working with dominicanos USA the
korean-american foundation
Jen chance is executive vice president
and chief operating officer of the
Historical Society any moment when the
question of immigration is so fraught
does it feel like you guys are doing
something a little bit radical here now
we're not a political organization we
don't make political statements we
really are doing what we are supposed to
do with our mission is to teach American
history so that's what we're doing and
we're just doing in a way that helps an
immigrant community just like helps the
general public the curriculum it turns
out was also created by immigrants you
are a green card holder mm-hmm from the
Netherlands yes but you don't have your
citizenship yeah not yet my students
tease me about it all the time when I
mentioned that I don't have it yet and
they say well you better pass otherwise
it would be very embarrassing Samantha
Rikers is the project's manager and a
class teacher what was the hardest
question to pair with an artifact so the
hardest question was what is the rule of
law which is first of all a difficult
question I think if you would ask an
American citizen well just a rule of law
they wouldn't be able to say nobody is
above the law everyone must follow the
law which is the right answer and I
connected that to the Boston Massacre
because John Adams actually represented
British soldiers and
he stated I did this because the rule of
law is more important if we're just
going to judge these people and that mob
rule ruled a country then we are not
going to be a civilized nation the
course celebrates American history but
doesn't rewrite it what are the
difficult chapters to teach well slavery
four-for-one and civil rights when we
teach about westward expansion in our
geography lesson we teach about Andrew
Jackson's Indian Removal Act it will
place a dense and civilized population
in large tracts of country now occupied
by a few savage hunters on display is a
statue of Osceola the Florida Seminole
who resisted surrender of native lands
to white settlers that was very
important to me because those are often
groups that are not included in the
questions on the test but we want to
show that they're also part of American
history and that the history of the
United States is very complicated and we
think that's important for new citizens
to know here the legacies of America's
past sit side by side with the promises
of its future this should never stop I
will you know recommend this course in
this project to anybody who's finally
took the decision of becoming an
American citizen you know the debate
over immigration is so heated it's so
fractious and it was really reassuring
and wonderful to see the sort of
deliberative process that these
immigrants are undertaking to become
part of our country it was really
wonderful it looks like a really cool
course I love the wine stain on the
loose I did not know that I learned a
lot life gets done over wine